boy you're so obedient even have to say
anything good afternoon my name is Jared
Cohen I'm the president of Carnegie
Mellon University and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to this historic
day in the life of Carnegie Mellon
University when I thank the members of
the string quartets who entertained you
before we chase them off the stage I
guess they're all members of the student
body of the school of music I'm very
proud of them we're very glad that you
could be with us today you are people
those most of you who are here with a
particular interest in public policy
people who care about the world's
problems from sustainability to health
care from poverty to social justice and
you care about them at every level
geographic and government local national
and global 40 years ago in 1968 it was
these same concerns than inspired
Carnegie Mellon to form a new school at
that time in the 60s American cities
were in turmoil they were struggling
with declining tax bases urban sprawl
suburban sprawl a serious sort really
got started cities were coping with
massive new public housing projects some
of them very ill conceived in highway
projects that reshaped entire
neighborhoods and not for the better
government often seemed out of touch
with the needs of city residents and
racial tensions erupted into deadly
riots that devastated many cities from
coast to coast in this country there was
a growing awareness of the effects of
pollution and especially poor air
quality in our cities and increasing
alarm about poverty and inequality
two decades before that time in the late
1940s Carnegie Mellon created the
graduate school of industrial
administration or GSA as was known then
now known of course is the temper school
of business that school transformed
management education by putting business
practice on a more scientific and
interdisciplinary footing and developing
and applying new analytical tools of
economics and operations research for
the problems of companies and markets
they essentially created the modern
business degree some young GSA GSI a
faculty members in the 60s led by
william cooper and Otto Davis better
known as bill and Toby asked what if we
could take these new tools of the
business world new tools developed at
Carnegie Mellon and apply them to the
pressing issues in the public sphere
what if we created a new school that
would teach students new systematic ways
to address social and government
problems and needs just as they had
addressed industrial organization and
marketing in the private sector it was
the right idea at the right time and so
with very substantial start-up support
from Richard King melon and his wife
Constance another the inspired deanship
of Bill Cooper the school of urban and
public affairs or supe open its doors in
1968 and around the same time a similar
commitment to advancing the public good
what's on the mind of a young h john
hines the third after working for his
family's company during the 60s he'd
actually joined the faculty at carnegie
mellon in 1970 but john hines his heart
was truly in public service and in 1971
he won a special election to become a
member of the US House of
Representatives after two more terms in
the house he became Pennsylvania's
United States Senator in 1976
during his years of service in Congress
John Heinz champion new initiative is on
aging international trade and finance
health care and as we all know
especially close to his heart the
environment he was truly a beloved
figure in the state and in this nation
Wiley recognizes one of the most
effective politicians of his generation
he was especially revered for his
willingness to work across the aisle on
projects of importance to the country he
believes strongly in bipartisan
cooperation and he lived his
professional life just that way Sarah
Heinz died in a tragic airplane accident
on April fourth 1991 in honor of his
life his immense contributions as a
senator and a recognition of his
inspiring influence on so many carnegie
mellon renamed its school of urban and
public affairs the h john hines the
third school of public policy and
management over the years of variety
graduate programs have been added to the
hind school successful masters programs
in public policy and management programs
in health care in the arts and
entertainment and in information systems
and in the process the hind school has
become a global school as well but
unites all of these programs wherever
they're taught is a practical
problem-solving ethos and the
application of analytical tools
technologies and creativity in the
search for innovative solutions in these
various areas I think it's fair to say
information systems degree programs in
particular have grown quickly providing
training that is relevance in both the
public and private sectors in recent
years the leadership of the highest
school has recognized two significant
and interconnected trends first the
growing power of information technology
as problem solving is providing the
basis for problem-solving tools in all
spheres of life and work with an
enormous untapped potential
especially for applications in the
public sphere second the growing
integration of the world's economy with
ramifications for every industry and
economic endeavor these trends as we
know are playing out in the careers of
recent high school graduates in will so
and will in the lives of new graduate
soon they've also been providing key
research directions for our faculty and
they're increasingly important to the
economic competitiveness of this region
and of our nation it's not too much to
say that the hind school finds itself at
this sweet spot if you will of at the
intersection of the trends I mentioned
and to the high school people that means
an opportunity an opportunity to reshape
itself boldly for today an opportunity
to renew and expand its dedication to
its founding vision it was indeed the
sense of opportunity that compelled the
Heinz endowments to provide generous
support for which we're all very
grateful and which helped to bring us to
this great event today we're honored to
have with us today to raise a Heinz
chairman of the Heinz endowments Theresa
we thank you for your remarkable
leadership of this foundation for your
wonderful support of this university and
the guidance we've received from you
over the years Andre Hines was on his
way here and may still be on his way
here in advance of his arrival I want to
acknowledge him and thank him he's not
only John Hines and trace behind his son
he's a member of the board I'll be in
doubt that Heinz endowments as his Jim
Walton our trustee who is also with us
today I want to also recognize Bobby
vaght the president of the Heinz
endowments and Jeff Lewis president of
the Heinz Family Foundation very
pleasing to be with us today for this
very important occasion to continue this
historic event it gives me great
pleasure to introduce to you the
chairman of the board of trustees
of Carnegie Mellon David Shapiro
thank you very much Jerry and on behalf
of the board of trustees of Carnegie
Mellon thrice I would like to on behalf
of all of us thank you for everything
that you do for the unit University you
and the Heinz family endowments but in
addition to that for everything that you
do for society in general you are truly
a remarkable person and we all are
blessed to know you so thank you as
chairman of the board of Carnegie Mellon
I would like to welcome you all to this
historic occasion my role today is the
sort of do the official things that have
to be done and although I hate reading
from papers I've been instructed that I
must read from this paper so I apologize
in advance and what I would like to do
is read to you a resolution that was
passed this morning by the board in
today's board meeting whereas in 1968
the school of urban and public affairs
was established for the study of public
policy and management and whereas in
1992 the school was named the h john
hines the third school of public policy
and management in honor of the late
Senator hines and whereas in recognition
of the growing importance of information
systems degree programs to the college
and its future the school of information
systems management has been established
along with the h john hines the third
school of public policy and management
forming the h john hines the third
college and whereas in october 2007 the
heinz endowments announced its approval
and support for this vision of for the
heinz college now therefore be it
resolved that an appreciation of the gin
rocity if Teresa Heinz and the Heinz
endowments for their long-standing
support and appreciation for their
encouragement and endorsement and
establishing the Heinz college we here
bright we hereby celebrate the
establishment of the h john ines the
third college and thank the heinz family
for their committed service and
dedication to the University and Theresa
thank you again
Carnegie Mellon makes structural changes
like this very infrequently but we
always make them purposely the trustees
are convinced that with the strength of
the public policy program coupled with
an expanded role for the information
systems program that we have a winning
combination greatly expanding the Heinz
College of ability to respond to the
needs of the community we also believe
that will attract new students and
support exciting scholarship and
research relevant to a broad range of
problems in the public and private
sector both in the US and around the
world the entire university will benefit
from this change which will open up new
problems for collaboration and
cooperation and in such areas as energy
environmental policy economic
development and government now i'm
leaving this grip for a second this is
actually what carnegie mellon is best at
it's right in our best tradition and I
think this is a really great thing it's
now my pleasure to introduce the acting
dean of the new hines college ramayya
Krishnan who also holds the William W
and Ruth F Cooper professorship of
management science and information
systems being Krishnan is well suited to
reflect on this new structure for the
school not only as a long time faculty
member but also because his own research
interest is in how internet and other
information technologies are spurring
innovative solutions to a wide range of
problems in both the public and private
sector so with no further ado Dean
Krishna
thank you David I don't have David's
excuse but i'll stick to my notes as
well so good afternoon and welcome we
have many students and faculty who are
not here watching this so welcome to
those of you are not here in in
Washington DC and Los Angeles and for
those of you are in Adelaide good die
all right good I might all right there
you go I'd like to begin by saying on
behalf of the faculty the staff and the
students of the eight John Heinz at
third college we do greatly appreciate
president co hanh and the board of
trustees for supporting and encouraging
this transformation of the hind school
to the Heinz College which will consist
of two schools or school of information
systems and management and a School of
Public Policy and management we are
deeply grateful to Teresa Heinz and the
Heinz endowments for long-term support
to the school's vision and for believing
this transformation and actually making
it possible it's important that I
acknowledge my predecessors in as Dean's
al blooms teen was here mark Hamlet and
most important of them all mark vessel
we would not be here if not for them
they had the vision and foresaw the the
societal scale deployment and adoption
of information technology and the
profound implications that this has had
for our political cultural and economic
systems we live in a world today where
there are more than 110 million users of
Facebook upwards of 200 million cell
phone users in the US and over 2.5
billion cell phone users worldwide we
are candidates for public office bypass
traditional news media to text send text
message
is about their campaigns to voters with
important campaign news and we're
literally hundreds and millions of
people have access to information
networks for conducting Commerce for
collaborating and for communicating so
what are the implications of these
changes these profound changes for
individuals or firms for markets for
society it's it's in studying these
implications that I think has catalyzed
our universities establishing this John
Heinz the third college so what I would
like to reflect on for a few minutes
what does it mean to have a school of
information systems and management and a
school of public policy and management
under one roof so first and foremost I
think looking at this internally there's
a tremendous amount of diversity that
lives and exists within the Heinz
College in terms of culture in terms of
interests in terms of geography and we
would like to find ways to truly
leverage the power and promise of this
diversity that exists within within the
Heinz College second I think this new
structure will permit us to innovate at
the intersection of information
technology and public policy while
enabling each school to really build on
and deliver on its distinctive strengths
so for instance the public policy and
management school has had distinctive
capabilities and strength and important
policy domains social policy health and
environmental policy and in the case of
the information systems and management
school an expertise in understanding the
economic and technological drivers of
digital transformation in key sectors
such as health finance and entertainment
so how might we innovate at the
intersection of public policy and
information technology will offer two
examples the first example is healthcare
it represents sixteen percent of the US
economy
there are 46 million uninsured people in
the US and it's widely recognized that
information technology is a key part of
the solution to reduce costs and improve
quality and avoid potentially deadly
errors the Department of Health and
Human Services even has a coordinating
role to help create interoperable
information technology to enable the
implementation of important policy goals
in this area of health care and IT
another example is the revolution in the
way digital content has gone how content
has gone digital be video or audio I
mean if you look at ipods we have a
hundred more than 150 million ipods in
in use today and as you think about
music and video and how this content has
gone digital it's really important to
recognize the role of intellectual
property rights in this domain how does
one price in the face of piracy how does
one think about broadband media policy
in a world where all content is digital
easily easily shareable and how should
value be added both to firms to markets
and to society I've given you about two
examples of the potential that lies in
co-locating students and scholars with
interests and information technology and
public policy to fully realize our
potential we have embarked on an
initiative which I call C squared
collaborate and connect I should warn
you I use C squared both as a noun and
as a verb as I will just a moment so we
plan to c square our programs within the
school so to collaborate and connect and
truly leverage the diversity lice that
lies within the college we will c square
our campuses i mentioned we have
presence in addition to pittsburgh in DC
and LA in an adelaide and you want to
really be able to connect these
different campuses we will c square with
our colleagues within the university
it's one of the great strengths of CMU's
and being able to do really cool
interdisciplinary work across
departmental boundaries and with our
organizational partners our alumni and
stakeholders we have put in
slabs and an example is I lab and the
Institute of Social Innovation with the
idea of trying to promote
entrepreneurship and innovation in this
important intersection between
information technology and public policy
so today we are celebrating something
important important not only for the
University but for society as a whole
and in the words of our founder in whose
name my chairs named after as well bill
Cooper who said we are here to create
men and women of intelligent action who
can change the world this has been the
historic mission of the hind school in
now behinds college and we will pursue
this quest with renewed energy so thank
you and it's now my pleasure to
introduce a distinguished 1978 graduate
of the Heinz policy program dr. Beverly
wheeler dr. wheeler is the executive
director of the District of Columbia
State Board of Education and
president-elect of the Carnegie Mellon
Alumni Association
my notes are short they told me I didn't
have long to speak that only had because
they know I am so in love with Carnegie
Mellon University that I could speak for
hours but I will not today is a
wonderful day today is a day of
celebration and I am so proud and I'm so
humbled to be here I arrived on Carnegie
Mellon's campus three months after the
first graduate of the master's program
from supa in 1972 and I never left
Rick's and Rick Stafford is one who was
here that day and I'm sorry that he's
not here today but today there are some
faculty members who were my faculty
members there who absolutely led me
through the process to love Carnegie
Mellon and to love education but there
were two men in my life who had a
profound effect on my profession and on
my desire for education they taught me
that education was to be pursued that
you should go to bar ends of the earth
to finally education and do whatever you
could to get it and if in fact you were
blessed to be educated it was a punt
incumbent upon you to use it for the
public good to make sure that if you got
the education that you shared it and
that you did something for Humanity
those people were my father who had to
in 1920 with a learning disability
actually do a sit-in at his Harrisburg
high school to get an education and Toby
Davis who was the Dean here I actually
remember when Toby invited me to be a
part of this great experiment it was
over lunch and it was the spring of my
sophomore year when he asked me
be a 3-2 student to actually leave the
joy of being an undergraduate student
but in my junior year to start graduate
studies I said yes of course because
Carnegie Mellon had taught me a lot of
individual skills but I wasn't sure how
I should package those skills and so the
school of urban and public affairs gave
me an opportunity to do that another
thing that Toby taught me was about the
iterative process and what we see here
with supa and behind school and the
Heinz college is an iterative process
where we learn how to do everything
different and better and more wonderful
I am so excited about today because we
have an opportunity to really look at
technology information systems and use
them with policy and to really think
about policy as we need to think about
it today now there are those of us
who've been around for a while actually
I'm celebrating my 30th hines reunion
this at this homecoming those of us who
thought we were the keepers of the
vision who wanted to make sure are we
moving too fast are we making sure we
have policy are we you know sending
people into the public sector I say
resoundingly yes I say we need to be
excited again today I'm also excited
just about the Heinz college because
it's as dr. Cohen said it's named after
a man who embodied public service a man
who embraced using resources to provide
good public policy and it emboldened us
now to go forward to do more when we
need good public servants doing good
public policy more than ever so I'm
proud to be here and I would like to
believe that Toby would be proud of us
as well thank you
I thought I'd now like to introduce a
current student at the hynes College
Quran de Bakker she is a master students
in arts management Thank You Beverly
again I just want to echo that only half
of all the students we are incredibly
excited and grateful for the opportunity
to step into the Heinz College in
preparing my remarks for this
celebration today I asked a couple of my
peers what makes the Heinz college so
special seems like a simple question the
rate the answers ranged from the faculty
to the resources like the Career Center
to opportunities to interact with our
peers from different programs socially
because sometimes the best ideas happen
over a cup of coffee but there was one
answer that permeated through all of the
answers and one answer that everyone
agreed upon and that was that the Heinz
college students have ambitions and that
the Heinz college students have a vision
for how to make their industries better
and they have a vision for how to make
their lives better and the Heinz college
as an entity uses and uses those
resources of the faculty of the services
and resources like the Career Center and
even those formalized social activities
to help us embrace the vision that the
high school was that supa was and that
is now the Heinz college so it is my
pleasure to ask miss Hines to join me at
the podium now we students here that you
have a young granddaughter and as you
know CMU likes to recruit students early
especially those with talent
oh it gives me great pleasure to present
you with the only children's Hines
college logo t-shirt
and in fact we have teachers for the
entire Hinz family thank you you're
welcome I know it is like a softball
team and last but not least it gives me
much joy to present you with this card
that is signed behind students that I
think embodies truly what we feel in
just having the opportunity to be in the
Heinz college and to receive our degrees
from such a wonderful institution
Thank You kuranda that was terrific and
thanks to all the Heinz college students
in honor of this occasion we are honored
to have as our guest speaker our friend
and advisor Paul O'Neill Paul is served
on the Heinz Dean's Advisory Council for
several years a council that in fact has
been invaluable in helping to support
the vision for this new college
structure that we are announcing and
celebrating today Paul understands well
the distinctive character of the Heinz
college as he should because throughout
his long and distinguished career he has
been a voice for a proponent of the
value of data-driven decision making
wherever he's worked in both the public
and private sectors he's had as well a
very deep experience in the transitions
and challenges of regions like ours and
especially our region which he loves
well as well as the nation please join
me in welcoming a longtime friend and
valued adviser back to Carnegie Mellon
the former US Treasury secretary the
retired chairman CEO of Alcoa the animal
Paul O'Neill
if i don't like getting prepared
speeches i hope you won't mind if I just
remind myself with my notes of the
things I thought were worth while saying
today I've lived most of my life at the
intersection of public and private
policy and information technology and so
to me this transition seems like a
natural evolution and an important
evolution at the same time because i
think if you join me and looking at
where we are in the world today we have
an ever greater need for people who
understand the details and nuances of
important publican and the private
policy decisions and how to engage
information technology and systems
analysis and giving us the prospect of
better answers and a better world for
all of humanity you know for me a lot of
this is frankly very personal I was
thinking when we were a standing bow
down below about Senator heinsohn how I
had known senator heinze this is of the
neighborhood if you will you know I have
this memory after I'd been here maybe
for a couple of years standing out on
walnut street by a Schiller's drugstore
for those of you who are local you'll
appreciate them and and the center heinz
would there you know dressed casually
and we had a conversation on the corner
and i noticed when we were done talking
he got in his Jaguar I think no
Teresa saying no I swear this is my
memory that he was standing by this car
media wasn't his and I was thinking to
myself I was thinking to myself this old
saw about Jaguar if you own one you
actually have to have to because ones in
the garage all the time so he's not
guilty of owning it just standing by it
I suppose but you know we had
engagements in public policy issues I
was in them in the federal government
from 1961 until seventy six before I
went back for a second round that my
wife thought was ill-advised and she was
right but I came to know him after he
was elected to the House and then to the
Senate and to engage him on public
policy issues but you know my fond
memories of our running into him in the
neighborhood and him being you know
clearly a person of superior
intelligence and intellect but of the
neighborhood at the same time you know I
never had a sense that he thought he was
better than anyone he just wanted to
make the world a better place and so I
think very much he would have
appreciated the transition that's going
on today yeah he would have found a much
in it that he saw earlier than most
people did in 1995 Teresa created in his
honor the Heinz Center on science
economics and the environment and that's
how Jerry and I really got to know each
other engaging with the founding board
of directors there and to seeing the
wisdom of his understanding of the
linkage of important public policy
issues and I would say even though the
height center doesn't have in its name
energy for sure the senator knew that
energy and environment are the same
subject they're not too different
subjects he knew that way before his
time and he tried to bring his
colleagues along to understand
we shouldn't have divisions over whether
economics was more important than the
environment or the environment more
important than economics and
understanding that science needed to be
our quest for understanding how to how
to tame and direct these important
elements of our society a way before his
time so I think he would have much
appreciated this transition that's now
happening I here at Carnegie Mellon and
i have to tell you for sure I appreciate
i thought i would tell you more about
living my own life at the intersection
of up these important subjects i see
them as truly the same subject so i got
i got recruited to go into the
government in 1961 actually I served my
first day in govern on July the third of
1961 I had degree in economics and I
spent a year at claremont graduate
school studying mathematical economics
and operations research and i accepted
an internship at the Veterans
Administration because they offered as
part of that internship the first 18
months learning about systems analysis
on how to program computers you know I I
didn't know now you're all you all know
that you need to prepare people with
that I didn't know I needed that but I
was dumb lucky enough to fall into
marrying disciplines that were
reinforcing and and helpful to each
other and so when I was recruited into
the VA at that time I think there were
one hundred and seventy two thousand
patients and the Veterans Administration
Hospital system and here was the subject
that was made to order how do you
optimize the right diet for a hundred
and seventy thousand people every day
and do it in such a way that it
satisfies their their desire for the
frequency of what they get and their
preference for different kind of foods
and do it all over the lowest possible
cost and use the consequence of the
complex biggest biggest ever
of its kind linear programming model to
solve the diet problem you know it was
it was a wonderful example of bringing
economics and operations research and
computers to the table at the same time
some of you are not old enough to
remember this I have to tell you in 1963
let's say when we first began running
this optimization optimization it took 2
hours and 45 minutes on an IBM 7090 for
to run one iteration of this gigantic
model today you could do it on your
laptop probably in about 45 seconds but
in those days it was an unbelievably
large problem we were trying to work on
so you know I moved from there I was
recruited after i had another year of
school and indiana got another degree i
was recruited into the what was then the
Bureau of the budget and here again i
found an intersection of information
technology and important public policy
problems because myocyte my first
assignment was figure out how we can
think in a in an integrated way about
the federal role in health and medical
care so I thought a good place to begin
would to know would be to know what is
it we actually do in the federal
government so I use the information
technology it was pretty primitive in
those days to discover for the first
time no one had known there were 26
different departments and agencies of
the federal government that were doing
something about how the medical care
they didn't tree their individual
intersections they were off doing their
own things because they were
independently authorized by committees
of the House and the Senate and and they
hardly ever talk to each other so there
was no engagement of important questions
like this if you have a limited amount
of resources and you have a problem of
people with kidney failure should we
invest our
in perfecting renal dialysis that is
cleaning up people's blood streams or
should we invest our research money in
figuring out how to overcome tissue
rejection so that when we do transplants
the kidneys don't get rejected you know
no one had ever had the ability to think
about those problems because no one had
ever imagined that there were important
intellectual intersections that needed
to be mine and I'm not here to tell you
there are easy answers to those kind of
questions only that information
technology for the first time began to
make it possible to think about worthy
questions and to work on them in a in a
in a concerted careful building way and
so and I was not too surprised some of
you will be going to remember this
because you're old enough in 1969 I had
telephone calls from Air Force One this
is like in June of 1969 and what
President Nixon wanted to know if we
change the the terms of the what we were
considering a negative income tax we can
no one could say those words out loud in
those times that was a ideologically
unacceptable but what we were working on
was a way to transform income assistance
for low-income people in the United
States and so Nixon and Ehrlichman and
Haldeman who were flying back from
Romania wanted to know run the computer
model at CDC and help us understand how
many people are affected by changing the
income support levels from sixteen
hundred dollars a family to twenty four
hundred dollars of family and here again
until about that time it would have been
impossible to have anything more than a
guess we were able to use the
demographic facts from the US Census
data and understanding state and local
distributions of different income love
that actually have a very good idea
about how much money it would cost a
surprise to provide different levels of
income support now you know I give you a
couple of those kind of examples because
for me these things absolutely have to
be together i would say information
technology alone is interesting but it
doesn't go much of anyplace in fact i
have to tell you without the human
animation and leadership even good
analysis doesn't do very much good and
so I've been in the time I've been
serving on the advisory group pounding
away on the subject of let's call
ourselves the leadership school not the
management school it's not that I don't
appreciate management but I'm here to
tell you its leadership that really
makes an essential difference in how we
have the potential to move our country
forward it's about leadership ideas and
I'm going to give you a couple of
examples of that you know I'm thinking
after I would served until January of
1977 and the government went to the
private sector again I want to make a
point that policy making public and
private sectors are a lot more alike
than they're different so that I found
information technology was essential to
beginning to understand the forest
products industry when I went to work at
international paper and to creating a
competitive cost curve so that one could
see where you were in in the context of
a world competitive activity and to and
to see early on how the world was
becoming ever more interconnected that
while we still had a conceit in this
country in the 60s and the 70s that we
were kind of alone and and an island
protected by oceans on both sides from
the rest of the world it wasn't true
even then and been clear to me for a
long time
that we were creating this growing
interdependence which we've now seen
with a vengeance in them last couple of
months and then when I was was fortunate
enough to be recruited to come through
al Cohen be the CEO you know what the
proudest things I have ever done was to
use information technology to provide a
basis for an enterprise of 350 locations
in 43 countries to be the safest
enterprise in the world not by
cheerleading but by using information
technology to put into cyberspace for a
hundred and forty-three thousand people
to see for 140,000 people every day to
see incidents that had occurred some
place in the world that they could learn
from almost almost instantaneously so
that we could use incidents things gone
wrong to learn and educate people and to
give people the basis so they could take
their own action to create a phenomenon
that unfortunately not a lot of other
places have yet figured out how to do
Dave and I were having a little
conversation before we came out his lost
work day rate is now down 75 percent
from where it was when they started
their own quest toward an incident free
workplace and I'm here to tell you it's
a leadership that it that articulates
the goal that's a crucial element and
then if you can marshal information
technology and move forward on public
policy it is really truly unbelievable
what can be accomplished in lots of
different ways in lots of different
places and they're still so much more to
be done so I'm take you back into the
government with me now in 2001 and after
911 you know after nine eleven i was in
tokyo and had just gotten there about 15
minutes before the first plane hit the
towers and so they sent a plane from
okinawa to pick me up to bring me back
and we flew overnight and when I got
back on the ground my people were
telling me you've got to convince the
president that we can't reopen the
market tomorrow this is now a Wednesday
night Wednesday night and the reason we
can't reopen the market is because the
information center of the computer
center that drives the stock exchanges
is under 30 feet of water I thought that
was a pretty convincing argument and so
I did convince the president we can't do
it we're going to do everything we can
to restart on monday morning and i have
to tell you if there's a famous picture
of some of us hillary clinton and me the
grass Owen the governor standing there
at the podium I had my hands behind me
with my fingers crossed that it was
going to work when we hit the button to
start the markets which we did you know
but it was it was a marvel of
information technology that let us
demonstrate that whether our buildings
have been knocked down our spirit wasn't
stopped it was really an important
moment and then we set out to figure out
where the money flows are in the world
that are supporting these evil things
and in the time that I was there until
the end of till the end of november in
2002 we were able to confiscate and a
four hundred million dollars worth of
money that we were only able to identify
and secure because of information
technology without it we had no hope
there was no way we could have
interdicted the money that terrorists
were using to attack civilization yeah
so it's made
you don't find it a happy example but it
is really an important of an example of
the combination of public policy and the
needs of public policy and bringing with
it information technology to change the
world in a very positive way then I want
to make a case that information
technology and public policy issued can
get you in trouble so that in 2002 I
kept saying you know I don't think we
should have another tax cut because I
think there's a threat we could have
another attack there's a there's a
crying a loud crying need to deal with
the issues of unfunded liabilities for
Social Security and Medicare was now
total 53 trillion dollars if you don't
know and we need to do something about
the ten thousand page tax code that
proves were not an intelligent people
and by the way if you run the computer
models and you believe the computer
models about the incremental difference
that another tax cut will make in the
fourth quarter of two thousand and four
which I know you're interested in
because that happens to be another
election season this incremental tax cut
will produce half of one percent
difference in GDP growth rates and it's
not worth it now I tell you all that
because this is the case of Public
Policy and good modeling and analysis
leading to leading you to a conclusion
that gets you fired
sometimes it's not such a bad idea to
get fired
you know it's not over and so I have a
message for the students today I'm sure
you are imagining how you're going to
bring together this intersection in a
way that makes a lot of difference to
you if you don't have an agenda of your
own I have one for you that I tried my
best to get Jim Wolfensohn to adopt he
was the head of the World Bank when I
was a secretary of the Treasury and I've
long been interested in in a global
economic development believing that
there is no reason why people everywhere
in the world not only can aspire to what
we're lucky enough to have but actually
enjoy what we have and so when Jim went
to the World Bank one of the things that
he did to his great credit was oversee a
process of creating the so-called
Millennium Challenge goals for 2015 and
one of those goals was that by 2015 at
least half of those people who had no
clean water in two thousand would have
it in 2015 and so I said to Jim you know
Jim what about the other half which he
didn't appreciate a lot but I've had I
had even the sterner idea for him which
he didn't like at all which is this i
believed we should put laptop computers
in every village in africa and in other
places around the world but particularly
in Africa they had to be uplinked in
cyberspace and every day they should
answer the question how many people in
your place have clean water today that
didn't have it yesterday not in 2015 and
frankly believing that if you don't
measure things and if you don't have
near term goals it's a pretty easy to
have long term goals that you regret
you didn't achieve when you get there
because you didn't do anything in
between and so if you want to do
something really important I think about
leadership goals that most people would
say are impossible make sure they're
highly desirable for human beings every
place in the world and then push on with
not only the ultimate goal but which
what you expect the world to accomplish
every day and by the time you get to
that day in 2015 that you set your
sights on you'll be really proud that
you made a difference and and the cost
change that makes civilization worthy of
the name thank you very much
it's not my pleasure to introduce to
race it to you who I that I don't really
need to do that do I this is such a
wonderful person she's intelligent she's
determined she's caring and she cares a
lot about this community and I'm sure
that many of you would have wondered
well you know why don't you just go off
and stay in Washington and never show up
around here and not care much about this
place you know she's my idea of actually
of the Pittsburgh community my wife and
I have now been here 21 years we came in
1987 we choose to be here you know we
could live wherever wherever we choose
to be here because this is a really
unusual community i'm not sure
Pittsburghers understand as well as they
ought to what a wonderful place this is
because it's a place where regular
everyday human beings make important
things happen people are engaged they
make a contribution it's not about
taking it's about giving and it makes me
really be really proud to be part of
this community and to call my friend
Teresa
but i also have notes but I've been
inspired and challenged as I was
listening to Paul and to Beverly and to
you you made me cry they did because
there's Paul says we all love Pittsburgh
have a place in our hearts that we may
not even be aware of that response and
when you've lived in Washington as long
as I have and I don't didn't choose to
stay in Washington I made a decision
that made me stay in Washington some but
I'm here I run away here as much as I
can but when you do you realize how very
special Pittsburgh is I always thought
of it even in the 60s when I was helping
with a little school Shady Lane school
trying to get for a little early
childhood model scholarship money is
full three and four-year-olds and I
remember going to go foil to ask for
twenty-five hundred dollars I had never
done that before and very nice man I
think the president of the Chairman
talked to me said well we know we only
do higher education I said I know that
but you know we have to get from here to
there and we're really trying to do
something very special about affecting
public schools in Pittsburgh and we have
to understand what we're doing and that
it works and then if it does we'll get
there he gave this our first twenty five
hundred dollars for pre-k scholarship
monies in Pittsburgh that's huge in
nineteen sixty eight or nine that was
huge so the point is in this city you
can feel emboldened as you are
challenged and hopeful that someone will
hear you and that's the spirit with
which my husband did everything and
certainly the spirit that I carry
and I would just like to talk to him a
little bit to your students particularly
about what the name of the school means
in terms of the man that I knew and
married the father of my kids the
congressman the senator most importantly
a passionate and joyful human being I
think I don't know if it was Paul's
mentioned the word not passion but
commitment something of that sort and
passion is what he had and if he was
intolerant in any way was for stuffed up
people who never had a question and
never wanted to listen to anyone's
question he did not like that so to him
the status quo was never good enough it
was always a better way of doing things
or is it better way of pushing the
envelope a challenging status quo always
a solution a problem looking for a
solution an opportunity he looked at
problems as opportunities and i have to
tell you the books on his bedside of
scientific american and chess an art so
he was a man of men ski magazine so he
he he really did and and this i'm not
saying these dissipate okie because
there is a link he was as equipment got
better and skiing so he was already a
very good nationally ranked the skier
know he was better now because he wanted
to turn better tennis he'd have to beat
anybody and he'd figure out something
how to do it better always getting
better well who you are living in a time
which appalled made a reference to now
on this great crossroads of transfer of
technology not transferred that's what
he did to that in those days was co
common eastern europe and communists and
that kind of problem today technology
transfer something else but you are
living in time up and opportunities that
will allow you to bridge not only
differences
and barriers but to create such
opportunities and heard of both
culturally governmentally societally an
NGO etc you have that ability just like
you use it in little ways no this tennis
or his ski turns or whatever it is that
we had as technology in those days which
wasn't a lot but we use that he was a
person that I think if you knew him he
was a born teacher in his heart except
to his own kids and me of course because
he was so demanding and when you and
when you have that morning noon and
night it's tough but but there was never
a dinner and we made a point of having
as much as possible family dinner time
except maybe twice a week and my boys I
think presented in some ways but they
grateful for it today they understand as
men what that meant but he really
enjoyed that kind of give and take in
curiosity and you would have had a lot
of fun with him and he would have loved
being here and pester you with questions
he cared about old people he cared about
and he was in his legislation created
the in the house actually with cord
pepper famous pepper was one of the
older members of the house and great
legislator in and who could never as a
Democrat bring about the creation of a
committee on aging but because this
young Republican wanted to co-sponsor
and introduced it with him it passed and
then he became the chairman of aging and
particularly of importance and I know
you deal with this was long term care
and he really studied that and was
concerned in 20 almost 20 years ago more
and if you talk to say and Eastern from
aciu his main concern is a big labor
leader
CIU his long-term care and how we're
going to look at that that's a big thing
you took people ARP you took to
insurance companies you name it he cared
about that from way back he cared about
the environment why did he care about
the environment because he was a
fisherman and a hunter not a hunter
hunter but he'll shut birds or anything
that flew and something but he did when
he had time but loved nature and his
most avid lovers of nature they are
great protectors of nature because they
want to go back and see that the animal
and the fish are still there and he was
also a fantastic shot as a matter of
fact beat the world champion he was just
a gift of guy let's face it difficult to
live with but the wonderful well how can
you be good when you live with someone
like that I was a bit of cool but but he
did and so just pushing the envelope and
learning all the time was it was
something that he did so everything that
he did really was about life was about
barriers to excellence or barriers to
people managing their lives or barriers
or stupidity in the part of either
policy makers or through ignorance and
so rather than give be he loved
government and he put he loved people
and he actually said if you really don't
love people you shouldn't be in
government because you'll be miserable
and you'll be a bad whatever you are
legislature governor etc and that really
what it means is if you have a passion
to come to high school to solve whatever
or prevent or create whatever
possibilities aren't there is because
you have a passion for essence and the
passion for good policy and the passion
for wellbeing whatever it encompasses
and it's that well being that I think we
should put a litmus on anybody running
for opposite their badmouth government
you don't run because you want to go
then do a good job not bad mouth it turn
it around and be smart about it
what you would say but that's what I
believe and I'm tired of people being in
Washington and sticking around and
bad-mouthing it all the time I I'd
rather they left came back and just turn
it around you know made it work in those
days I saw government working bipartisan
fashion and this is the other point I
want to make we're not going to solve
the problems of this world any if we do
not know how to talk to one another in
government in society across governments
across countries transnational you name
it we don't even have language yet for a
lot about transnational global agenda
and understandings or laws in many
respects I mean roles that can be
implemented we don't have the history of
trust to do it owning the old-fashioned
way of said League of Nations in those
days they did and out the you and they
don't we need own trust and it's up to
you really with all that disco can give
you all the inspiration that we as older
people in this community and experienced
can share with you and all that you're
great teachers and faculty here can give
you you have an awful lot going for you
and I know you have a passion or you
wouldn't be here and so now I just can
look to see if I have a supposed to say
something but I wanted to show you that
because I think that was his heart and
that was what this I think has meant to
allow that Pittsburghers were brought
change about in the city not just John
he was a product of it and as in many
respects is poor a reflection of it
though he didn't grow up here but I was
so proud and Paul decided to leave
Washington
it takes guts in that city to say what
you believe and what is right in your
mind I think he was right anyway and I
had the great pleasure to work with Paul
at the hyde center of environmental
sciences and economics and saw many
problems but very exciting opportunities
and my only sadness is I can't be queen
for a day over a year and just make all
these things happen quickly I like that
sometimes and that be booted out but
anyway so already a lot has been said
about the new school the new college and
so I don't need to say that anymore
about that but and also about Pittsburgh
and what its sense of possibility and
light is it is the Renaissance city
after all and it's the Renaissance city
because poem nagpur RK melanin and and
governor lawrence and others had the
forethought or at least the good
reactive instincts to clean up the city
when needed desperately to be done or
they knew they couldn't get people here
but they did it and that spirit as stay
there and has broadened unfortunately
the times have changed and the kind of
infrastructure that pittsburgh used to
have in terms of the old leadership
infrastructure doesn't quite exist so
leadership comes from different places
now which is else is healthier just more
laborious but it's healthier and so this
great Civic comradeship and and trust
now in this community I think that's
different from the past man women
minorities even you name it was before
it was all the old dad's or sold
whatever you want to call them some of
them great some of them all right and
and so I I'm excited by seeing what's
HAP
at Carnegie Mellon do this and I on
behalf of our family I want to express
my congratulations to Jerry Cohen to you
David and and you on behalf of the board
to Dean Krishnan and the faculty and to
express our great support for what the
heights college has needs to schools and
I would say to you students that every
single one of the challenges we face
today just to recap our only
opportunities for brilliant new
innovations I happen to be very
interested in work a lot on
environmental toxicities on prevention
on environmental health and there are
some horrific things you see if you look
at the research but they're also amazing
new ways of measuring how to treat how
to prevent how to prevent cancer and not
go there in the first place we know a
lot how to prevent autism we know we are
doing it here in Pittsburgh right now
and treating some of it it's not well
known yet but we know this place is a
mind of knowledge of that kind and there
are other centers like this in America
but not a lot not a lot and it's so
exciting every time I came I came here
the other day and I went to a meeting at
the McGowan Center center for
regenerative medicine without President
Bobby bat and I only had four hours and
it was like going to Disneyland fao
schwarz Disney World and George Lucas
taking me by hand I was so excited about
the possibilities in there and what I
saw my own eyes so I just say these
things are here remember that and so we
have global poverty's to face generally
water-related refugee status
desertification hunger disease one of
the Hinds award one is that just won an
award this week George Reese's 35 years
old from UCSF brilliant guy and his
whole big thing is to figure out how to
detect and do and cure all the big
diseases that kill the world malaria
aids etc he was able to develop a slide
this little big that in 20 less than 24
hours identify SARS and you'll say that
any virus that comes down the way within
a few years is going to be able to be
identified immediately that's another
technology time we're all in but
Pittsburgh with CMU and Carney and doug
pitt biotech is it the crossroads of all
of these possibilities in medicine in
materials in systems in in management
you name it and then you have a great
technical side of the University and
also we artistic side of the university
yet you know performing arts fine arts
great English when you really are a
lucky group of people so just know that
horrible things you see and you read
there's a lot of knowledge already just
keep asking the questions why does it
happen why does this happen it's not
necessary and that's my that's my
driving force the work that I do I don't
want to give people monies to go to
hospital I want to give somebody monies
to make them well so they don't go to
hospital if I can if I had a choice and
we know enough to know how to do that a
lot better than we're doing and we also
know that if we have tremendous problems
in our water systems in our air with
metals and minerals metals most enough
and we have huge incidents of attention
deficit and all of the developmental
neurological problems as well as autism
and other things how can we expect kids
in school to study how can you expect
that parents to understand even what's
happening to them they don't because we
didn't have those problems these kids
are just being bad they're not they said
and right here at Western psychiatric
and New York Times had a cover story for
in the Sunday magazine five weeks ago a
big story on pediatric bipolar disease
and it so happens that Pittsburgh which
is historically being very big in the
chemical side of psychiatry is at the
forefront of the study and they have 250
such children here five a week and they
don't want to believe that they are
manic-depressives they want to start off
you know with this or this or this and
then they end up saying only lithium
treats them they don't know it's
permanent but the incidence of autism
and all these diseases is skyrocketing
in our part of the world as well as some
others and so the problem is and I
already know what some of the problem is
now how do we stop this so it's very
exciting to know that we know as opposed
to parents friends of mine who have
grandchildren and children or artistic
etc and they just afflicted because they
don't know what to do they don't know
what so this is very exciting times and
you have to till the bad story so you
know how good the answers can be and
that they really had to be grabbed and I
believe that and that's why I can soak
it up and not get drunk and go to work
because otherwise I would be very
depressed and instead I get angry and
then I work and for exasperated I guess
is a better story so I will just end
with a little quote
that Jack said some somewhere I don't
remember a brighter future is within our
grasp not because the road is level not
because the wind is at our backs not
because the sun shining but because our
people have the spirit to overcome
obstacles to dream a better America and
to build it and the world to thank
thank you very much Teresa and thank you
for that wonderful quote probably a
quote that applies at any moment in time
but it seemed particularly apt at this
moment in time Thank You Teresa for your
support your leadership not only as it
relates to Carnegie Mellon but for our
region in our nation thank you Paul for
being a Pittsburgh hero and honoring us
with your presence no one represents
better than you the straddling of the
two sectors I can put it that way in the
crucial role of information systems in
that my congratulations to Krishnan or
his leadership into his predecessors
especially mark vessel for his great
leadership in getting us to this moment
today
Beverly are a wonderful representative
of the many alumni of the high school
now the Heinz college we're delighted
you could be here today and kuranda
thank you for representing our student
body soil there's a lot of reason for
hope and excitement when you see our
students and have a chance interact with
them and David thank you for
representing our our university so well
in the board of trustees and I want to
acknowledge the many many trustees who
found the time to be here today for the
special event we really appreciate it
the Heinz college is being created
really at a remarkable time I think
Teresa is right our problems are
obviously daunting but there is reason
for hope and it is our people as Senator
Heinz has said and in particular the
people of the Heinz college we're very
proud of you and we wish you well we'll
be watching closely we know you'll be
very very successful indeed
congratulations
historic events occurring a melon cannot
be complete without bagpipes and you're
going to get your bagpipes indeed not
just bagpipes but a bagpipe procession
of everybody in this room or all that
are willing to join us all the way down
to hamburg hall now bagpipe recessions
come with instructions and that's my job
so we're going to lead the way let us go
first and then you're going to be asked
to follow us row by row starting in the
front here there will be able bodied
assistance to indicate how you should do
that and very importantly on your way
out there will be staff ready to hand
you a t-shirt like the one that
Theresa's grand child received and this
is very important because one of the key
events and Hammer hammer call is going
to be a photo op and these t-shirts are
to play an important role so take your
t-shirt follow the person in front of
you don't trip we'll see you in a little
while
you